they call her the Secretary of evil
today 97 year old imguard F was found
guilty of aiding the murders of more
than 10 000 people
all prisoners here at stood off
concentration camp where she worked for
the Nazi SS Commander for two years
was more or less equivalent to this
sentence
the crematorium worked 24 hours a day
and still could not manage
to
deal with the number of bodies it had to
burn
detainees at Nazi extermination camps
were gassed shot starved and often
worked to death at least 65 000 of those
forced through the so-called death gate
at stuttoff didn't survive
this document was a very big extent was
sending people to death
in the archive we're shown orders
believed to have been countersigned by
imguard F during her time as a secretary
this is probably her signature here
she's never admitted any guilt for the
horrors committed here
this is the route the prisoners would
have taken every day and this is
imguard's office window she's always
denied knowing about the atrocities
carried out here prosecutors ask how
could she not see what was happening to
the tens of thousands of people being
held here how could she not smell the
smoke from the fires as the piles of
bodies were being burned four years
difference between us Manfred was a
child prisoner in stuttoff at this time
he thinks his baby brother was among
those killed
there were people screaming for their
lives in the gas chain but only for a
few minutes until the gas finally killed
them
but it was impossible not not to know
what happened there were bodies being
carted
openly through the camp the 97 year old
initially tried to avoid Justice fleeing
from the authorities
old age means this could be the last in
a string of Nazi trials as Germany tries
to confront its past
it is a healing process and it is a
process who comes to terms with the
history of our families
German people for a long long time like
very much to talk about the victims but
not about those who have been
responsible for all the guilt a two-year
suspended sentence for her role in the
crimes committed here means ERM God F
will not die in jail
but today's verdict proves that justice
has no time limit and age is no defense
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Germany